es el primer paso para investigar
crímenes de guerra en palestina una sala
preliminar de la corte penal
internacional determinó que palestina es
un estado parte del tribunal y que
abarca los territorios ocupados por
israel incluyendo cisjordania jerusalén
del este y la franja de gaza- la
aclaración es una respuesta a la
solicitud de la fiscal general fatou
bensouda que pidió a la sala especificar
los territorios donde pueden llevarse a
cabo investigaciones la autoridad
nacional palestina que solicitó una
investigación formal en 2018 celebró la
medida
la resolución es un mensaje para los
perpetradores de crímenes que sus
crímenes no estarán sujetos a un
estatuto de limitaciones y que no
quedarán impunes israel que no hace
parte de la corte ni reconoce su
jurisdicción denunció una supuesta
persecución legal
hoy el tribunal demostró de nuevo que es
un organismo político y no una
institución judicial la cpe ignora los
crímenes de guerra reales y en su lugar
persigue al estado de israel
palestina espera que se investiguen los
excesos cometidos por israel en la
represión de las llamadas marchas del
retorno de 2018 que dejaron más de 273
palestinos muertos y más de 16.000
heridos
y también los bombardeos en la franja de
gaza- en 2014
sin una fuerza policial propia la cpi
depende de la voluntad de los estados
por lo que es poco probable que israel
entregue voluntariamente a posibles
sospechosos además el tribunal también
podría investigar a miembros de grupos
armados palestinos que son mencionados
en los informes de la fiscal